bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
alors parmi les thèmes qui vont être
abordés cet après midi par les sénateurs
dans l'hémicycle ici il y aura une
question sur le sommet social qui s'est
ouvert ce matin à paris avec notamment
le discours du président de la
république que vous avez pu suivre sur
notre antenne ce matin une question
également sur l'exception culturelle et
les négociations entre les états unis et
l'union européenne une question d'yvon
collin sur les inondations dans le
sud-ouest de la france
et puis parmi les questions également la
vôtre gérard césar bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous aller interpeller le
gouvernement sur le boycott chinois sur
le vin alors gérard césar il faut
préciser que vous êtes de la gironde que
vous êtes également viticulteur que vous
présidez ici au sénat le groupe vigne et
vin et c'est vrai que vous êtes très
inquiet des mesures de rétorsion prises
par la chine à la suite des mesures
prises par l'union européenne contre le
dumping chinois sur les panneaux
solaires est ce que vous estimez que
c'est restauration vont toucher
directement nos exportations de vins est
ce que déjà des effets se font sentir
oui exactement j'ai la preuve formelle
que des importateurs chinois ont stoppé
la venue des contenaires français de
vins de bordeaux
mais ça va être vrai pour d'autres
régions françaises et c'est dommage
parce que la filière souffre
actuellement et nous on nous comptons
justement sur la commission européenne
c'est la question que j'ai posée
d'ailleurs au ministre de l'agro
alimentaire tout à l'heure par rapport à
la taxation justement de ces panneaux
solaires par la commission européenne et
qui allaient l'incidence par rapport aux
vins de bordeaux en particulier surtout
au moment où nous sommes à vinexpo
mais la france est solidaire de cette
décision de bruxelles
de contrer le dumping chinois contre les
balles sur les panneaux solaires oui la
france est solidaire
mais les allemands aussi solidaire mais
il faut que les 27 pays le soit mais
pour autant il faut négocier et négocier
rapidement faut pas qu'on attende les
mesures antidumping que la chine ne
propose ou la commission pour pouvoir
justement abordé tous ces points donc il
ya un problème d'urgence et c'est pour
ça que je pose la question c'est cet
après midi au ministre l'agroalimentaire
vous dit qu'il ya des containers qui
sont déjà bloqués on se l'est en ce
moment ça ça fait partie je dirais des
négociations c'est pour faire pression
c'est pour faire peur oui mais pour les
viticulteurs c'est dommageable parce que
c'est si et si en parallèle et c'est le
cas les chiliennes sont en train d'
abaisser leurs droits de douane
ça veut dire que d'autres pays de
l'hémisphère sud en particulier mettront
en pratique un certain nombre de règles
qui aujourd'hui sont défavorables pour
eux mais qui aujourd'hui peuvent aller
favorisés par rapport à l'audio
justement là qu à la proposition de la
commission européenne
vous étiez j'imagine ce dernier jour à
vinexpo la grande messe autour du vin
qui se tient à bordeaux et où viennent
des acheteurs du monde entier
on est ce que vous avez quand même senti
sur place que les acheteurs chinois
étaient moins présents ou moins
intéressés ils sont toujours présents
très intéressé mais aujourd'hui il ya
joe dit je disais à l'instant la preuve
que certains importateurs ne veulent
commence à boycotter parce que il faut
savoir qu'un conteneur qui part de
france mais un mois pour arriver en
chine est l'importateur a peur que entre
temps les droits de douane au monde ce
qui les pénaliserait donc à l'arrivée
donc par précaution
aujourd'hui ils stoppent les
importations donc tout est gelé si ces
jolies en partie en partie mais c'est
donc nos inquiétudes sont prévues très
vivant est ce que vous ne pensez pas à
vous parler du vin chilien par exemple à
l'instant que le danger pour le vin
français la concurrence ne vient pas sur
tout justement de ces vins étrangers qui
ont de plus en plus le vent en poupe et
qui ont fait beaucoup de progrès il faut
bien le reconnaître
oui il ya une concurrence forte mais les
vins français et européens sont de
qualité
et je trouve qu'aujourd'hui par rapport
au marché
nos veines en toute leur place est dans
chaque foyer en particulier dernière
question gérard césar
on a évoqué ici au sénat et notamment
monsieur de 10 nickel rapporteur du
budget la sécurité sociale ici au sénat
l'idée d'une taxe sur le vin est ce que
cette idée est toujours dans l'air ou
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement l'a hanté il faudrait dire
au nom de mes collègues du groupe vigne
et vin qui rôde il recouvre toutes les
tendances politiques du sénat que nous
sommes unanimement contre justement
cette taxation est aujourd'hui la
viticulture la filière n'est pas besoin
de taxe supplémentaire car elle souffre
la consommation de vin a diminué et on
sait bien que les accidents de la route
malheureux lors ont pour origine
d'autres sources que le vin merci
beaucoup gérard sais que je vais vous
laisser rejoindre l'hémicycle du sénat
on va effectivement pouvoir suivre en
direct tout à l'heure sur notre antenne
votre question c'est guillaume garot le
ministre chargé de l'agroalimentaire qui
y répondra geneviève fioraso la ministre
chargé de l'enseignement supérieur au
gouvernement s'installe à votre place
alors que le sénat examine en ce moment
même et bien le projet de loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur bonjour madame
hominis major merci d'être avec nous
alors dans le figaro on pouvait lire
cette enquête
aujourd'hui un quart des diplômés des
écoles de commerce débuteront leur vie
active à l'étranger escape péril en la
demeure
tant mieux ça veut dire qu'ils ont un
parcours à l'international qui seront
mieux armées ensuite pour exporter nos
produits nos services qui re montée en
gamme grâce au projet de loi notamment
sur l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche
grâce à l'action globale du gouvernement
et tant mieux il est sûr qu'il revient
de travailler ensemble c'est ce que
j'avais à vous dire mais il est assez
normal qu'en début de carrière quand ils
ont moins de charges familiales
finalement qu'ils utilisent cette
période de leur vie us encore assez
mobile assez disponible pour allait
acquérir une expérience à l'étranger
donc moi ça ne m'inquiète pas plus que
cela
d'autant que bon on en conclure
bien sûr tous les prix nobel bon tout le
monde ne sera bas prix nobel mais tous
les prix nobel ont un parcours à
l'international ont effectué des séjours
à l'international et ils sont revenus
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on continue à les
faire revenir c'est hier qu'on soit
suffisamment attractif optimiste joyeux
confiant dans l'avenir pour les faire
revenir
oui parce qu'il peut y avoir une double
lecture un de cette enquête on peut
aussi y voir un contexte une morosité
ambiante attendait le fait que le
gouvernement n'a peut-être pas toujours
aussi donné le sentiment de soutenir
l'esprit d'entreprise
ces derniers mois on peut avoir aussi
cette double lecture de cette enquête
alors là vous n'avez pas vu ma loi vous
n'avez pas regardé les rives n'y ai pas
regardé les décisions et les
orientations du premier ministre du
président de la république et les
assises de l'entrepreneuriat norma loy
ya tout un dispositif pour au contraire
développer l'esprit d'entreprise à
l'université développer le travail en
équipe
non ce que je voulais dire c'est que
delta en réalité quand on regarde par
exemple dans les écoles d'ingénieurs le
delta par rapport aux années aux dix
années qui ont précédé
il est de 2 à 3% alors quand on semble
découvrir un sujet qui en fait un sujet
assez banal est normal oui disons on
peut dire qu'on parle déjà depuis
plusieurs années effectivement une sorte
de fuite des cerveaux en france non il
ya une mondialisation de la connaissance
mondiale est une chose mais j'ai eu à
washington par exemple une quarantaine
de post doc c'est à dire après le
doctorat qui sont allés acquérir une
expérience aux états unis et puis avait
un peu vieilli il avait envie de fonder
une famille
tous voulaient revenir en france tous
parce que le système de protection
sociale environnement familial un
service de petite enfance efficace ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans tous les pays
donc finalement il ya un moment où ils
reviennent et c'est très bien ils
reviennent mieux armés mais aucun
n'était encore revenu s'ils étaient tous
il avait tout ce monde et avait postulé
à aller passer un concours ils allaient
moi je l'encouragé à l'est aussi dans le
privé faut aller dans le public et dans
le privé on a besoin de chercheurs dans
le privé c'est la partie faible notre
recherche secteur privé et quand on voit
cette polémique autour de votre projet
de loi sur les cours enseigné en anglais
dans certaines universités est ce que
vous dites je sais vous voulez bien sûr
parler mais du coup du coup ça me fait
penser à ça est ce que vous dites que
cette polémique est totalement has been
justement alors de cette mondialisation
et du fait que tout circule
je ne stigmatise ray personne parce que
j'ai envie que nous convergeons donc je
m'aperçois qu'en ayant mis des
conditions de jeu pensé maintenant des
décrets d'application dans des
circulaires et j'invente au niveau de la
loi comme l'accompagnement avec des
cours en français comme le fait d'avoir
toujours un petit peu de cours en
français pourra culturel les étudiants
étrangers aux français de tenir compte
de cette connaissance du français même
partielle dans l'attribution du diplôme
en accompagnant cette mesure est bien
nous sommes arrivés à une convergence
c'est à dire que ce qui me paraissait
surtout injuste c'est que 600 écoles 600
formation et peut être dispensé
complètement en anglais dans les écoles
sans que personne ne trouve rien à
redire depuis 15 ans mais c'est vrai que
plus de 50 50 pour cent des jeunes
concernés étaient issus de familles de
cadres ou de famille plutôt aisée mais
quand on dit à l'université où il y en
avait que 100 90 alors qu'elle accueille
55 % des étudiants quand on dit bah ça
doit être permis aussi sous conditions à
l'université pour tout le monde pour des
jeunes qui à priori au moins les codes
internationaux ont au moins eu
l'occasion de rencontrer de se
confronter à des cultures différentes et
bien l'interdire à ces jeunes je trouve
que c'était une injustice sociale en
plus haut qu'il faut le faire en
l'encadrant
ça restera marginale ça nous permettra
d'accueillir les étudiants coréens
indiens brésiliens qui sont tout de même
les marchés qu'ils permettront
d'améliorer la balance notre commerce
extérieur
on a pu voir que la polémique était un
peu retombée puisque la discussion a été
beaucoup moins vive ce matin au sénat
autour de ces cours en anglais qu'elle
ne l'avait été à l'assemblée nationale
on a fait preuve de pédagogie et de
répétitions donc petit à petit ça a fini
par pénétrer question très politique s
qui aura une majorité ici au sénat pour
adopter votre projet de loi soit
vendredi soit lundi prochain
je ne sais pas moi est ce que ce que je
voulais savoir un débat extrêmement
ouvert il ya des convergences
il ya des divergences qu'il faut c'est
que nous exprimions en sérénité et que
chaque partie puisse montrer que c'est
un intérêt d'ordre général
après on pourra avoir des divergences
sur tel ou tel dispositif et on
s'exprime
heureuse on les a entendus nombreux ces
divers jeux de façon calme oui de façon
calme et en tout cas elle existe et
c'est bien sûr les groupes alliés du
groupe socialiste ici au sénat pour
l'instant que ce soit les écologistes où
les communistes voire même les radicaux
de gauche n'ont pas vraiment l'intention
de deux voté pour ce texte je déballe
mêmes informations que vous vous avez
l'impression que ça évolue concerne
concernant notamment les radicaux les
radicaux de gauche moi j'espère qu'on
entrera une solidarité gouvernementale
et châtre et que chacun fera les efforts
nécessaires
mais après chacun est responsable de son
vote je rappelle que ce projet doit est
centrée sur la réussite étudiante
il est soutenu par les mouvements
étudiants pour moi ce qui compte c'est
la légitimité du peuple j'allais lire un
donc donc les étudiants puisque
l'université les quand même fait pour
servir les étudiants et puis par
ailleurs la recherche intérêt général de
la recherche
oui on peut rappeler effectivement
l'objectif du projet de loi c 50 % de
diplômés dans une génération ça c'est
l'objectif qui vous tient à coeur c'est
l'objectif qui me tient à coeur
et puis davantage de jeunes issus de
milieux modestes qui parviennent à faire
des études qui ont accès aux études
supérieures puisque ça s'est dégradé
on a baissé de cinq points dans la
démocratisation de l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur
on a baissé de cinq points aussi dans la
réussite en licence elle à 33%
elle à 60% pour des filières non
sélective en allemagne voyez le fossé
qu'il nous faut rattraper
donc c'est ça l'urgence et l'urgence est
aussi d'instaurer des quotas
par exemple pour les bac professionnel
en bts qu il faut faciliter toutes ces
passerelles un fait partie si on veut
les faire réussir et pas les faire
échouer par défaut à l'université parce
qu'ils n'ont pas être acceptées en sts
pour les bac techno parce qu'ils n'ont
pas été acceptés dans les iut et bien il
faut les orienter en priorité là où ils
réussissent d'ailleurs au bts et
réussissent à plus de 50% les bac pro
dans les bts en revanche il
ils réussissent à trois et demi pour
cent en licence pour les bac techno ils
réussissent à neuf et demi pour cent
seulement par rapport aux 33% licence à
l'université où ils vont par défaut
parce qu'ils sont pas préparés à l'est
ils réussissent à 68% dans les huttes et
donc voyez la différence
moi ce que je veux ce que je souhaite à
ce que mon gouvernement serait ce que le
président de la république souhaite
c'est que les jeunes réussissent c'est
votre avenir
et la réduction de ces inégalités la
passe par l'imposition de quotas par des
quotas mais je ne dirais pas
l'imposition parce qu'ils vont être
négociés sur le terrain entre les
recteurs au nom du ministère et puis les
responsables d'établissements où les
présidents d'université et on tiendra
compte et des domaines et la spécificité
des territoires dont vous voyez on est
bien dans un dialogue responsable
très bien merci beaucoup je ne les
remercierai est venu en direct sur notre
plateau
je vais vous laisser rejoindre
l'hémicycle puisque la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement va
démarrer dans quelques instants en
direct sur notre antenne le projet de
loi de geneviève fioraso sur
l'enseignement supérieur et bien vous
pourrez suivre la suite de la discussion
se fera à partir de 16h30 sur notre
antenne voilà jean pierre bel le
président du sénat s'installe au plateau
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la présidence du sénat c'est pas le
perchoir comme à l'assemblée nationale
mais c'est le plateau est donc séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement je vous l'aï dit tout à
l'heure le gouvernement qui va être
interpellé sur les inondations dans le
sud-ouest de la france ces derniers
jours mais également sur l'ouverture de
la conférence sociale ce matin à paris
par françois hollande
autre question celle de roland ries le
sénateur maire de strasbourg qui va
interroger la ministre de la culture
aurélie filippetti sur l'exception
culturelle et puis roland ries deviendra
ensuite sur ce plateau pour en discuter
avec nous gérard césar on l'entend du
tout à l'heure sur le boycott par la
chine du vin français
et puis jean louis carrère le président
la commission des affaires étrangères du
sénat lui interviendra sur la situation
au mali les troupes françaises qui sont
toujours engagés au mali et c'est
laurent fabius le ministre des affaires
étrangères qui est présent cet après
midi au sénat qui viendra lui répondre
parmi les autres thèmes qui seront
abordés cet après midi et bien il y aura
la rentrée scolaire comment va-t-elle se
passe et ce sera une question de la
socialiste françoise cartron et c'est
vincent peillon
le ministre de l'éducation qui est
présent à cet après midi et qui lui
répondre et qui lui répondra directement
une autre question plus sociale celle ci
est bien c'est celle de la communiste
marie france beaufils elle interpellera
le gouvernement sur la future sur la
fermeture par nom de l' usine michelin a
joué les tours le ministre des finances
pierre moscovici il n'est pas au sénat
cet après midi c'est fleur pellerin la
ministre déléguée aux pme qui lui
répondra donc voilà pour l'ensemble des
questions abordées
cet après midi vous voyez un contexte
originel
les jean pierre bel voilà vient d'ouvrir
lancement à l'instant la séance on suit
ces questions d'actualité on se retrouve
après avec nos invités abdallah sion et
les réponses
la parole est à monsieur gérard roche
pour le groupe
udi us et ce président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
la deuxième conférence sociale s'est
ouverte ce matin elle doit traiter des
retraites certes mais aussi d'emploi et
de formation
par ailleurs une réforme de la politique
familiale est à l'étude ainsi qu'une
réforme de la formation professionnelle
est aussi le problème de la dépendance
donc vous ne luttez pas les sujets et on
peut s'en réjouir et même vous en
féliciter mais vous semblez les aborder
les uns après les autres sans qu'à nos
yeux la cohérence de votre action soit
évidente
pourtant le financement de la protection
sociale est un tour les charges sociales
pèsent sur la compétitivité et l'emploi
allons même qu'une partie d'entre elles
couvrent des risques de solidarité
nationale c'est le cas des charges des
branches santé et famille la solution de
bon sens et de fiscaliser ses branches
en remplaçant les charges sociales par
exemple par la tva sociale
or ce n'est pas du tout ce que vous avez
choisi le faire et ça nous le regrettons
les charges demeurent et vous créez le
cic eu un crédit sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés par nature c'est un système
complexe à effet différé qui n'a donc
rien à voir avec une baisse directe des
charges
en fait pour le compenser vos compter
sur deux choses la fiscalité locale qui
augmentera
suite à la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités et pour le département
suite au poids des prestations sociales
et vous comptez aussi sur une
augmentation de la tva qui est prévue
dès le 1er janvier prochain
enfin plus que d'engager une réforme
systémique des retraites
c'était une nouvelle réforme
paramétrique que nous devons nous
attendre
on parle d'augmenter la durée de
cotisation
le taux on parle de désindexation est
rien bien sûr les régimes spéciaux qui
choque nombre de nos concitoyens en
amont
on a peur que la boîte à outils
deviennent un bric à brac et qu'en
sera-t-il
ah ouais quand même et qu'en sera-t-il
quand il faudra financer la dépendance
dans ces conditions monsieur ministre ma
question est simple
quelle est votre vision d'ensemble du
financement de la protection sociale
merci la parole est à monsieur françois
lamy ministre chargé de la ville merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur avant de répondre à votre
question je voudrais exprimer à la
solidarité du gouvernement à laquelle je
sais ça ce sila autre assemblée
enverrait les victimes des inondations
dans l'autre pays
le président de la république sera cet
après midi on met des pyrénées pour
réaffirmer cette solidarité active cela
monsieur le sénateur vous m'avez a
interrogé 1 sera vaste panorama de la
vie sociale de notre pays
vous savez que le premier ministre et
une partie des membres du gouvernement
sont actuellement présents à la
conférence sociale
c'est un moment important de la vie
démocratique de notre pays
vous l'avez vous même souligné pendant
200 jours 200 participants membres
d'organisations syndicales et patronales
mais aussi représentants des
collectivités territoriales vont
débattre de l'ensemble des sujets que
vous avez évoqué ce n'est pas
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
une grande messe de plus mais bien
l'illustration de la méthode du
gouvernement
un véritable moment de dialogue et de
négociation permettant un de dégager à
des compromis sur les enjeux majeurs de
la vie sociale de notre pays avec ses
fameux corps intermédiaires qui a été si
souvent décrié ces dernières années la
dernière conférence sociale à avait
permis d'aboutir à des résultats entre
autres un accord majoritaire sur
l'égalité hommes femmes dans la fonction
publique
aujourd'hui 1 le gouvernement a voulu un
placé à cette deuxième conférence sous
le signe de la mobilisation un pôle
emploi la majorité des tables rondes y
seront consacrés à la fois sur la
réforme de
la formation professionnelle mais
également sur l'amélioration des
conditions de travail des salariés
la grande conférence sociale sera
également bien entendu un temps de
concertation sur notre modèle social sur
les services publics et bien entendu sur
la préservation de notre protection
sociale
le rapport moreau a été rendu à la
semaine dernière aujourd'hui la
concertation va être lancé une table
ronde sera entièrement consacrée à la
question de notre protection sociale et
toutes les pistes de réflexion tous les
aspects du financement ils seront
abordés ensuite à l'issue de cette
concertation
vous serez saisir de réforme législative
importante permettant de préserver notre
modèle social dont la justice il insiste
sur ce dernier mot ainsi le dialogue
social et la démocratie parlementaire se
complèteront et j'espère monsieur le
sénateur que vous serez avec votre
groupe au rendez vous merci la parole à
monsieur roland ries ce pour le groupe
socialiste
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres madame alice la culture mes
chers collègues il y a quelques mois ma
collègue catherine tasca ici présentes
vous avez questionné sur la position du
gouvernement quant à l'exclusion du
secteur audiovisuel les domaines de
discussions entre la commission
européenne et des états unis pour un
futur accord de libre échange
transatlantique
vous lui aviez répondu alors avec force
que le gouvernement était déterminé à
défendre l'exception culturelle et cet
engagement n'avait rien d'une posture
parce que la france a su parler d'une
seule voix et d'une voix forte
notre pays a finalement obtenu gain de
cause nos voisins européens se sont en
effet progressivement rallier à notre
position visant à exclure l'audiovisuel
du champ des négociations est ainsi
rappelé un principe intangible
l'exception culturelle européenne ne se
négocie pas
la culture ne saurait être une
marchandise comme les autres
mais voilà pourtant que ressurgit delà
des plus hauts responsables européens le
président la commission la voie de la
contestation de ce principe d'exception
culturelle
monsieur barroso a fait resurgir la
polémique en parlant de ce programme
anti mondialisation totalement
réactionnaire
madame liste ces propos sont
inacceptables
il est inacceptable un double titre tout
d'abord parce que ce n'est pas seulement
la position de la france qui est
attaquée mais également celle des autres
états membres que nous avions convaincu
et du parlement européen lui-même car
les députés de strasbourg seuls
représentants élus par le peuple
européen ont fait leur la défense de
l'exception culturelle
mais par ailleurs monsieur barroso outre
passe à l'évidence son mandat faut
rappeler que le président la commission
est en charge de faire respecter les
traités y compris pour ce qui le
concerne lui même il ne comprend pas
manifestement pourquoi nous défendons et
passion l'exception culturelle
madame la ministre il faut dès lors le
lui rappeler et réaffirmé que la france
et l'europe ne s'oppose pas à ce que les
cultures de tous les pays et en premier
lieu la culture américaine puisse
souffler librement nous nous inquiétons
simplement de cette tendance à la
marchandisation généralisée comme si
toute production y compris les
productions de l'esprit devait se
soumettre aux lois du marché
on sait par exemple que dans le domaine
du cinéma la commission souhaite réviser
les règles la territorialisation des
dépenses et notamment les règles
relatives à l'origine des biens et
services
cela remettrait en cause complètement
les politiques publiques en matière d'
aide au secteur cinématographique et
audiovisuelle madame la ministre
en conclusion pouvez-vous nous rassurer
nous assurer que le mandat de
négociation sera bien respectées par la
commission quelle initiative le
gouvernement entente il prendre pour
s'en assurer
merci la parole à madame aurélie
filippetti ministre de la culture de la
communication
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur roland ries vous l'avez dit la
france a obtenu une grande victoire avec
un mandat très clair qui a été confiée à
la commission européenne la semaine
dernière
c'est ce mandat il prévoit l'exception
culturelle c'est à dire de sortir de
l'accord de libre échange avec les états
unis
et produit culturel et audiovisuel se
demande à quoi qu'en disent certains et
fût ce le président de la commission
européenne lui même ce mandat il est
déterminant il est définitif la
commission ne pourra pas revenir sur ce
mandat
évidemment elle peut demander de
nouvelles directives aux états membres
mais ses états membres devront alors de
nouveau se prononcer à l'unanimité et la
france comme elle l'a fait par la voix
de nicole bricq vendredi dernier
s'opposera à toute remise en cause de
l'exception culturelle
c'est une grande victoire c'est une
victoire non seulement pour la france
mais pour la diversité culturelle en
europe et nous n'étions pas seuls
monsieur le sénateur vous l'avais dit la
voix du parlement européen son vote à
une écrasante majorité en faveur de
l'exception culturelle a été déterminant
de même que la position du parlement
français qui a adopté notamment à
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière à l'unanimité une résolution
défendant l'exception culturelle
nous avions aussi le soutien de nombreux
artistes de ministre de la culture d'une
quinzaine de pays européens d'artistes
de cinéastes de gens de professionnels
de la musique de l'ensemble des pays
européens donc nous avons mené et gagné
une belle victoire en faveur de la
diversité culturelle
nous continuerons ce combat contre cette
volonté de la commission européenne de
détricoter ce qui fonctionne et la
communication cinéma est un exemple de
ce qui nous inquiète
aujourd'hui les états comme les régions
doivent pouvoir continuer à investir
dans le cinéma et pour cela il faut
qu'on conserve des règles de
territorialisation de ces aides qu'ils
soient évidemment compatible avec le
marché intérieur mais qui ne remettent
pas en cause la possibilité pour les
états comme pour les collectivités
locales de soutenir d'investir dans le
cinéma c'est un enjeu majeur et c'est
pourquoi avec l'allemagne avec la
belgique avec l'autriche
j'ai demandé à la commission de revenir
sur la date butoir du 28 juin pour
rendre son texte sur la communication
cinéma
merci la parole est à présent à marie
christine blandin pour le groupe
écologiste
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur vincent peillon
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur le président cher collègue
monsieur le ministre la navette
parlementaire du texte qui crée les
écoles supérieures de professorat et de
l'éducation les aspects s'achève pour
que les formations soit effective dès la
rentrée 2013
leur préparation a été utilement
anticipé mais les remontées que nous
avons au sujet des travaux visant à
l'accréditation des sp nous laisse des
craintes trois points appelle notre
vigilance les contenus pédagogiques les
intervenants les moyens sur les contenus
les maquettes des masters métiers de
l'enseignement de l'éducation et de la
formation
présentés dans les différentes académies
nous interroge sur la place effective de
l'enseignement professionnels pratiquent
la double tutelle ministérielle ne
saurait donner priorité à la seule
approche disciplinaires aux dépens de
nécessaire mise en situation suivie d'
analyse pour les futurs professeurs
le changement doit être perceptibles par
ailleurs la loi de refondation de
l'école énonce des cadres de contenu à
ce jour absent des maquettes parmi
lesquels l'élaboration des parcours
artistiques et culturels la pédagogie
coopérative l'utilisation du numérique
comme outil de travail collectif
la résolution non violente des conflits
sur les intervenants
j'attire votre attention sur l'absolue
nécessité de laisser place aux
formateurs qui garde une activité
d'enseignement primaire ou au secondaire
il semble pour l'instant écartée au
profit des universitaires et des
professeurs du fm à temps plein il reste
aussi à construire les interventions
coordonnées
des acteurs de l'éducation populaire de
l'éducation culturelle et artistique
volonté du parlement
enfin sur les moyens la création des
espèces au sein des universités
nécessite que soit réaffirmé qu'elles
disposent de leur propre budget et
qu'elle ne serve pas de variable
d'ajustement
monsieur le ministre quelle forme
prendra votre demande aux universités
pour qu'existe a volé réel de
professionnalisation et comment comptez
vous être garant au sein de la cotutelle
des avancées que représentent les sp
tels que nous les avons conçu dans la
loi merci monsieur vincent peillon
ministres éducation nationale monsieur
le président madame la présidente
blandin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vos préoccupations sont juste
parce que la remise en place d'une
formation des enseignants ce sera sans
doute le vecteur le plus important pour
permettre demain la réussite de nos
élèves
tous les pays qui ont su faire à la fois
une formation progressive l'entrée
progressive dans le métier et la
professionnalisation dont vous avez
parlé ont pu progressivement résorbée la
difficulté scolaire qui dans notre pays
s'accroît encore il faut donc que nous
soyons extrêmement vigilants aux trois
points que vous avez évoquées et je
remercie j'en profite profondément le
sénat les sénatrices les sénateurs et
tout particulièrement votre commission
pour le travail qui a été conduit nous
serons en dernière lecture lundi mais la
commission a déjà travaillé a permis
d'enrichir le texte sur vos trois points
de vigilance avec ma collègue geneviève
fioraso et le travail des trois
directions qui sont associés nous avons
veillé je veux vous rassurer à ce que
d'abord les maquettes avec les exigences
qui étaient les nôtres pour ces master
soit respectée la remontée des dossiers
que j'ai pu examiner en détail lundi et
nous les présenterons en commun avec ma
collègue le 1er juillet à lyon on permet
de déterminer trois groupes d'université
minoritaire dans lesquelles le travail à
ce stade mérite d'être profondément
revue parce que les exigences qui
étaient les nôtres sur les deux points
ne sont pas aujourd'hui au rendez vous
ce serait reproduire les mêmes erreurs
que notre pays a déjà pu commettre dans
le passé et je le dis avec netteté
l'école supérieure du professeur à
l'éducation sera aussi une rupture avec
les instituts universitaires de
formation des maîtres
enfin nous aurons cette formation
professionnalisante nécessaires au
travail des enseignants deuxièmement
tous les professionnels doivent être
associés les universitaires bien sûr
pour des contenus l'exigence
disciplinaire la didactique mais aussi
les praticiens de terrain qui doivent
continuer à enseigner dans leur classe
mais être déchargées pour pouvoir
s'associer au travail de l'école
supérieure et pas à plein temps comme
vous l'avez rappelé et aussi ceux qui
oeuvrent dans un certain nombre
d'associations et en particulier les
associations péri éducatives qui ont
d'ailleurs permis de construire notre
système d'enseignement de ce point de
vue nous avons veillé à ce qu'il y ait
des moyens et j'ai encore donné ordre
aux recteurs que parmi les milliers de
postes que nous créons plus de 6000 à la
rentrée certains soient précisément
affectés pour la décharge des
professeurs et j'ai demandé aux
inspections générales de se mobiliser
pour que là où il ya des défauts de
compétences les inspecteurs pédagogiques
régionaux
ils sont 15 cents les inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale les inspecteurs
généraux puissent aller s'occuper des
enfants en situation de handicap du
numérique ou d'autres formules je veux
donc vous rassurer mais tout cela se
fera dans la plus grande transparence et
vous serez informés au cours des
semaines qui viennent de l'évolution de
ces travaux merci la parole à madame
marie-france beaufils pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances mais je comprends bien que
c'est madame fleur pellerin qui répondra
les salariés de michelin à joué les
tours sont sous le choc suite à
l'annoncé de 730 suppressions d'emplois
sur les 930 existants
les salariés ont appris cette nouvelle
par voie de presse un matin la méthode
est particulièrement violent
les représentants des salariés n'ayant
même pas été informés de ce qui se
tramait en haut lieu
dans le même temps monsieur sénart pdg
du groupe a affirmé je le cite nous
avons tenu informé les principaux
membres du gouvernement et l'elysée de
notre projet par conséquent il n'est pas
apparue comme une surprise les élus tour
en jouent quant à eux ont été tenus à
l'écart
la direction de cette multinationale a
décidé à terme de rayer de la carte un
site français alors que mondialement son
activité est en expansion
son résultat opérationnel a grimpé de
25% l'année dernière à 2,4 milliards
d'euros
un salarié michelin après 34 ans de
service gagne 1450 euros par mois la
richesse accumulée par michelin s'est
faite essentiellement sur le dos de
l'ensemble de ces travailleurs et on
voudrait leur faire payer la note alors
que les dividendes ont augmenté de 250%
depuis 2008 c'est inacceptable combien
de centaines de vie familial modeste
brisé pour la seule satisfaction d'une
minorité d'actionnaires
une telle décision devrait être déclaré
illégal
notre proposition de loi contre les
licenciements boursiers avaient cet
objectif vous vous y êtes opposés alors
que la totalité des sénateurs
socialistes s'étaient prononcés
favorablement à nos côtés en février
dernier cette restructuration sur le
plan international ressemble à une
délocalisation déguisée ce sont 6
milliards investis dans les pays
émergents pour les trois prochaines
années et seulement 800 millions déjà
prévus pour la france sur six ans
comment pourrez-vous peser pour que les
choix de michelin puisse favoriser
l'industrialisation de notre pays ne pas
pénaliser le site et les salariés de
joué-lès-tours le plan social proposé au
michelin est en deçà est en-deça de
celui de 2009 et surtout de celui signé
à toul elia quelques années les
conséquences seront donc lourde pour la
touraine ou 27 1286 tourangeaux sont en
recherche d'emploi les citoyens
attendent de votre gouvernement des
réponses sur l'emploi la reconnaissance
du rôle des salariés la
réindustrialisation de notre pays
ils ne peuvent
effectué que voudrait détruisiez leurs
droits et leurs acquis par la loi qui
transpose l'ani quand allez vous
interdire les licenciements boursiers
pour que de telles situations ne se
reproduisent pas merci madame fleur
pellerin ministre chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises de l'innovation et
de l'économie numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice beau fils avant de répondre
concrètement à votre question je
voudrais avec vous avoir un mot pour les
salariés de joué les tours qui sont
attachés à michelin et qui vivent très
cruellement la décision du groupe perdre
son emploi c'est c'est une épreuve pour
ses salariés pour leurs familles c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement suit avec la
plus grande attention les annonces qui
sont faites par le par le groupe
il est important de préciser de quoi il
s'agit précisément
d'abord bien sûr l'arrêt de l'atelier
poids lourds de lusine de joué les tours
dont l'activité serait transférée à la
roche sur yon
c'est bien entendu l'annoncé la plus
difficile du plan de michelin puisque
cela entraînerait la suppression de 730
emplois sur ce site
le gouvernement demande à michelin qu'il
n'y ait aucun départ contraint
l'entreprise
l'entreprise a pris l'engagement de
proposer un autre poste dans le groupe à
chaque salarié concerné il faut
également que ceux qui souhaiteraient
rester dans la région se voient proposer
une solution et surtout que le site pour
suivre sa vocation industrielle
le gouvernement sera particulièrement
vigilant au respect de ses engagements
arnaud montebourg et michel sapin seront
extrêmement attentifs au sort des
salariés dans l'emploi est supprimé
toute personne qui perd son emploi à
cause de michelin devra retrouver un
emploi grâce à michelin mais les
annonces de l'entreprise comporte aussi
leur part de bonne nouvelle puisqu'elle
souhaite en effet développer la
compétitivité de ses outils de recherche
et développement et de production en
france
à cet effet michelin prévu un
investissement d'environ 800 millions
d'euros en france de 2013 à 2019 dans
plusieurs sites industriels et dans son
centre de recherche et développement le
développement d'une usine de pneus poids
lourds très compétitif à la roche sur
yon dans la capacité sera doublée et où
100 millions d'euros seront investis le
maintien de l'activité de produits semi
finis à joué-lès-tours activité dans
laquelle serait investi 22 millions
d'euros et enfin l'augmentation de la
capacité de production de pneus génie
civil et agricoles ainsi que de produits
finis à montceau les mines le
puis étroit avec au total près de 200
millions d'euros d'investissements sur
ces sites et plus de 300 emplois créés à
tout cela s'ajoute la modernisation du
centre mondial de recherche et
d'innovation à clermont-ferrand où 220
millions d'euros seront également
investis
michelin fait donc le choix de
moderniser son outil de production
d'investir de créer des emplois en
france mais aussi d'engager des
adaptations difficile très difficile
même sur le plan humain sur ce dernier
point je le redis madame la sénatrice le
gouvernement sera extrêmement vigilant à
ce que chaque salarié trouve une
solution qui lui conviennent et est ce
que les emplois soient créés en local il
veillera à ce que dès vendredi michelin
assume toutes ses responsabilités
d'employeur dans le dialogue qui va
s'engager avec les salariés merci merci
la parole
yvon collin pour le groupe du rdse merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'agroalimentaire de
la forêt elle est un peu l'actualité
puisque le président de la république
est en midi pyrénées aujourd'hui aux
côtés des populations touchées par ces
intempéries en effet depuis plusieurs
mois notre pays connaît un épisode
météorologiques exceptionnellement
perturbé ces derniers jours la situation
est devenue très critique puisque au
delà des dégâts matériels très
importants nous devons déplorer trois
décès le bilan de ces intempéries
s'annonce très lourd pour plusieurs
secteurs de notre économie je pense
notamment l'agriculture au tourisme
très affecté dans certaines de nos
régions en première ligne de ces
inondations à répétition l'agriculture
bien sûr se retrouve gravement sinistré
l'absence de soleil et les pluies
incessantes avait déjà fortement
perturbé
l'état d'avancement des semis
aujourd'hui des violents orages et la
grêle ne font qu'ajouter difficulté en
détruisant des récoltes à peine parvenu
à maturité sur l'ensemble du territoire
trois cent mille hectares sur est
ravagée par les intempéries et à ce
stade les organisations agricoles
estiment les dégâts à plus de 500
millions d'euros dans le seul sud ouest
des viticulteurs les producteurs de maïs
et les arboriculteurs s'inquiètent des
conséquences financières
certains sont assurés d'autres pas les
classements calamités agricoles sera
inévitable pour beaucoup
beaucoup d élus vont vous solliciter
sans doute sachez comment niveau je
soutiendrai bien sûr les maires du tarn
et garonne dans leur démarche d'autant
plus que les financements européens sont
très conditionné vous le savez à mme la
ministre à l'effet pour les cultures les
aides sont ouvertes aux parcelles
cultivées ou couverte pour l'élevage de
montagne c est dépendant des taux de
chargement en prairies et là aussi les
intempéries ont perturbé la montée dans
les estives
la situation est donc dramatique comme
on le constate encore aujourd'hui le
ciel n'est pas fait d'être clément c'est
pourquoi madame la ministre j'en appelle
à votre volontarisme pour venir en aide
au secteur agricole
quelles sont les mesures que le
gouvernement entend prendre pour
faciliter l'indemnisation des
professionnels et comment allez vous
garantir l'avenir des milliers
d'exploitations actuellement en
souffrance et surtout en grande
difficulté je remercie
eh bien merci la parole à madame cécile
duflot ministre de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais d'abord dire
effectivement qu'au nom du gouvernement
comme l'a dit mon collègue le ministre
lamy nous avons une pensée particulière
pour les trois personnes qui sont
malheureusement décédées dans les
inondations
le gouvernement vous l'avez rappelé est
très mobilisée suite aux intempéries de
cette semaine le président de la
république et manuel valls seront cet
après midi à saint béat en haute garonne
delphine batho était hier dans le sud
ouest et stéphane le foll se rend
également ce soir sur place les services
de l'état apportent partout à chaque
instant leur soutien aux populations qui
sont actuellement sinistré sur le plan
des secours pour vous répondre d'abord
puisque nous devons faire face à
l'urgence tout a été mis en oeuvre pour
protéger les populations près de sept
cents sapeurs pompiers et militaires de
la société sis de la sécurité civile
travaillent aux côtés des gendarmes
policiers agents et services de l'état
et des collectivités pour venir en aide
aux sinistrés
3200 personnes ont été évacuées et mises
à l'abri
au moment où je vous parle quatre
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile
est ce la gendarmerie ont été mis à
disposition des secours dans l'ensemble
des pyrénées dans les vallées certains
villages ont subi des dégâts extrêmement
important les reconnaissances se
poursuivent afin d'identifier de
déterminer leur ampleur nous serons
particulièrement attentifs à la
situation de ces territoires
il
les par ailleurs le gouvernement est
tenu régulièrement informé de la
situation des communes de côte-d'or
touchée cette nuit par des orages d'une
rare intensité
concernant l'indemnisation des sinistrés
le gouvernement sera très attentifs et
mobilisés et tous les instruments seront
utilisés rapidement je tiens à vous
indiquer que suite aux inondations de
l'automne dernier toutes les communes
des hautes pyrénées qui avait demandé le
classement en état de catastrophe
naturelle l'ont d'ores et déjà obtenu
sur le plan plus particulier des
questions agricoles monsieur le sénateur
colin il ressort les premiers constats
que c'est la viticulture qui est la
principale filière touchée avec des
dégâts considérables sur les vignobles
notamment celui du fronton au dessus de
votre département
les grandes cultures sont également
touchés les pertes de récoltes en
viticulture et en grandes cultures
résultant de la grève vous le savez
monsieur le sénateur sont assurables et
de ce fait ne relève donc pas du régime
des calamités agricoles
en revanche le régime des calamités
agricoles sera mobilisable et est
mobilisable en cas de perte de fond un
h'pital à la grêle il est possible que
cela puisse être le cas
concernant les difficultés encore
rencontrer pour les estives et les
demandes de dérogation qui seront donc
faite aux règlements communautaires par
les éleveurs
je peux d'ores et déjà vous dire au nom
du gouvernement qu'elles seront accordés
une fois le recensement des dégâts
effectués les quatre circonstances
exceptionnelles sont prévues dans le
cadre européen
le ministère l'agriculture ses services
ainsi que les services de l'état sont
mobilisés pour consolider dans les
meilleurs délais en lien avec les
professionnels
un bilan de l'ensemble des dégâts
occasionnés stéphane le foll a par
ailleurs demandé la mobilisation de
mesures d'urgence supplémentaires qui
ouvriront la possibilité d'un
dégrèvement sur la taxe sur le foncier
non bâti pour les parcelles touchées par
la grêle et une prise en charge des
cotisations sociales auprès de la
mutuelle sociale agricole
l'ensemble des sujets sont donc un prix
merci merci à damas ministre la parole
est à présent jean claude carle pour le
groupe ump
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur les gens du voyage qui
parcourent notre territoire en grand
nombre cause pour certains d'entre eux
assez régulièrement des ordres et
violence et je voudrais par deux
exemples montré combien les élus sont
impuissants et désarmé devant des
attitudes ignorants
à ignorant le droit des populations à
vivre tranquillement
je ne ressens aucun sentiment
discriminatoire envers ces communautés
qui ont un mode de vie différent et que
je respecte
nulle volonté pour moi donc de les
stigmatiser mais simplement la volonté
de montrer la réalité
dimanche 16 juin alors qu'une
manifestation sportive se dérouler sur
le terrain communal de frangy en
haute-savoie 70 caravanes de gens du
voyage ont voulu s'y installer
délaissant une heure dac est une aire
d'accueil situés à proximité
l'adjoint au maire s'est interposé en
déclinant sa qualité d'élu il a été
violemment prise à partie n'est qu'à ces
quinze jours d'arrêt de travail
profondément choqués d'avoir été
violenté sous les yeux de 150 jeunes
enfants et notamment de son fils de 10
ans les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues et je tiens à saluer et à
rendre hommage à l'action du préfet et
des gendarmes ils ont été donc dirigés
vers une autre aire d'accueil mais
personne n'a été inquiétée alors qu'hier
un jeune homme qui manifestait devant m6
dimanche lors de l'émission du président
de la république a été condamné en
comparution immédiate à deux mois ferme
assortis d'un mandat de dépôt
y aurait-il deux poids deux mesures
effectivement le jeudi 23 mai à montrer
20 en seine et marne épisode similaire
son maire a d'ailleurs écrit à monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur lui
expliquant le déroulement de cette
journée 200 caravanes d'une communauté
liées à la mission évangélique des
tsiganes de france ont forcé le passage
pour s'installer sur un espace vert
intercommunale protéger le maire a lui
aussi été l'objet de menaces et
d'intimidation verbale et physique
il se souvient des dégradations
occasionnées par de précédents passages
qui ont coûté des centaines de milliers
d'euros un coût exorbitant pour toutes
les communes qui connaissent ce genre d'
acda graal malgré la bonne volonté des
élus le phénomène prend de l'ampleur en
raison du nombre de plus en plus
important des gens du voyage de leurs
exigences et de leur comportement
ils ont des droits certes ils ont aussi
des devoirs mais comment pourrait-il le
comprendre tant les messages envoyés aux
délinquants par madame la garde des
sceaux qui qui dit nos prisons sont
pleines mais vide de sens sont
déresponsabilisant alors madame la
ministre
comment envisagez-vous de leur faire
respecter la loi de la république comme
à tout citoyen afin de pacifier
al'approche de l'été une situation qui
devient merci merci monsieur le
président la parole en numérique
escoffier ministre chargé de la
décentralisation
merci monsieur président à mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur monsieur président karl le la
solidarité gouvernementale fait qu'à
l'heure actuelle le président de la
république accompagné par le ministre de
l'intérieur se trouve sur les sites
mêmes en hautes pyrénées et dans les
pyrénées dans les hautes pyrénées et
dans les haute garonne donc le président
remise intérieure m'a chargé de vous
apporter la réponse à la question qui
est la vôtre vous avez d'abord rappelé
les circonstances dans lesquelles
l'adjoint au maire de cette commune de
frangy a été agressée s'est trouvé avec
un et le nez fracturés et pour essayer
d'éviter que des gens du voyage ne
viennent s'installer de façon illicite
sur un site qui effectivement n'étaient
pas disposés à aller à les accueillir
puisque aussi bien dans cette commune
qui est de moins de 5000 habitants
il n'y a pas de site qui soit distingué
pour accueillir
je voudrais avant de répondre à
spécifiquement à votre question dire
combien le ministre d'intérieur mais le
gouvernement tout entier veut saluer
l'engagement de l'ensemble des élus qui
tous les jours ne comptent pas leurs
efforts pour répondre à tous les
problèmes qui se posent pour apporter
une médiation chaque fois que possible
sur les différentes circonstances sur
lesquelles ils sont interpellés et qui
dans tous les cas dans tous les cas
cherche à apporter les meilleures
solutions alors s'agissant du problème
particulier que vous avez exposé sur la
haute savoie je voudrais vous assurer et
je le fais
en lien avec madame taubira notre garde
des sceaux que l'ensemble des mesures
ont été prises pour que l' enquête soit
immédiatement et radicalement engagé et
que soit mené avec la plus grande
rigueur pour préciser les circonstances
exactes dans lesquelles s'est passée
cette agression dans lesquelles se sont
passées ces circonstances parce que bien
entendu il n'est en aucun cas acceptable
qu'un élu de la république se trouve
agressée dans les circonstances que vous
avez rappelé et c'est un point auquel
nous tenons particulièrement
alors au delà des désordres que vous
avez rappelé cela ceux de la seine et
marne
et puis d'autre que vous avez évoqué le
je voudrais indiquer qu'il n'est en
aucun cas qu en aucun cas nous ne
remettrons cause le choix des gens du
voyage qui ont choisi de vivre une vie
non sédentaires mais de la même façon il
sera exigé qu'ils mettent en oeuvre
aussi bien leurs devoirs que leurs
droits et dans des équilibres que l'on
attend bien entendu du respect de la loi
parmi ces mâts d'ambition il y a parmi
ces dispositions il ya celles qui
protègent le droit de propriété et donc
sur ce droit de propriété il n'est pas
acceptable que nous ne revenions que
nous ne mettions pas en oeuvre
délibérément les mesures prises
notamment celles qui sont à tout moment
arrêté définit avec le conseil national
de
le conseil national de de nos gens du
voyage et sur lesquels nous travaillons
ensemble
merci madame la ministre merci la parole
est à jean louis carrère pour le groupe
socialiste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
ma question porte sur le mali et
s'adresse à monsieur laurent fabius
avant-hier a été signé un accord décisif
monsieur le ministre entre le
gouvernement de bamako et les
représentants touareg du nord-mali c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour le peuple malien
c'est un succès pour la communauté
internationale et c'est aussi un acquis
de notre diplomatie
je voulais le souligner monsieur le
ministre alors que le mali allait
basculer dans les mers des pires orist
les forces armées françaises que je
salue salue très chaleureusement et les
forces africaines ont préservé
l'intégrité de ce pays de 14 millions
d'habitants au coeur du sahel après
l'opération militaire nous enclenchons
une dynamique de développement
économique messieurs les ministres 3
milliards d'euros ont été annoncées à
bruxelles en mai pour redonner un avenir
à une jeunesse désoeuvrée construire
beyrouth ouvrir des écoles amener l'eau
et l'électricité dans les villages
éradiquer les trafics et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui nous faisons un pas vers
la réconciliation nationale ô combien
difficile
messieurs les sénateurs larcher
chevènement monsieur le président nos
échanges avec les députés mal hier en
particulier nous l'ont bien montré
au delà du seul vote à l'élection
présidentielle fin juillet c'est bien à
une réconciliation durable que nous
devons travailler ma question est la
suivante comment nous assurer que
l'accord de ouagadougou prospérera en
termes de décentralisation de
représentation et de développement de
toutes les populations du nord-mali vous
le savez monsieur le ministre
conditions du redémarrage de la
démocratie dans ce pays
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur laurent fabius
ministre des affaires étrangères le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
chacun a en mémoire c'était il ya six
mois à peu près jour pour jour le moment
où le mali allait tomber sous les mains
des terroristes et à quelques heures
près le président de la république a
pris une décision qui était très
audacieuse nécessaire et vous l'avez
soutenu je vais vous en remercier nous
sommes six mois plus tard et comme l'a
excellemment résumé le président carrère
la sécurité a été rétablie dans le pays
les financements nécessaires pour leur
développement économique sont rassemblés
et enfin le 18 juin a été signé à la
fois par le gouvernement malien et par
les rebelles touareg un accord qui il y
a quelques semaines était inespéré je
pense que c'est un succès lorsqu'il y
avait chez qui il faut le dire mais
lorsqu'il ya un succès et que la france
y est pour beaucoup
il faut le reconnaître alors qu'y at il
dans cet accord intérimaire
il y a en 25 articles deux grandes
parties la première partie c'est comment
faire en sorte que les élections du 28
juillet se passe bien et dans le calme
et la deuxième partie c'est une fois que
le président républicain était élu
gouvernement a été constitué
comment faire selon votre souhait
monsieur président carrère pour que ce
qui n'a pas été fait dans le passé était
la reconnaissance de la spécificité du
nord soit assurée l'accord est bon il
est excellent il y a deux dispositions
particulier l'article 16 articles 17 qui
prévoit des mécanismes particuliers
d'une part une commission mixte de
sécurité pour vérifier le cessez-le-feu
et d'autre part un comité de suivi et
d'évaluation qui sera présidée par le
représentant spécial du secrétaire
général des nations unies avec toute une
série de parties prenantes notamment la
france qui vérifiera que ce qui est
contenu dans l'accord soit appliqué
ça ne suffira pas il faut de la bonne
foi de partie
hot il faut que l'élection permettent de
dégager un président ou une présidente
puis un gouvernement qui a une en ce
sens mais nous les français nous y
sommes évidemment et deux y serons
extrêmement attentifs
un dernier mot peut-être n'avez-vous pas
eu en main tous
l'accord préliminaire qui a été signé
mais je voudrais vous lire le dernier
article arty 20 sacs puisqu'il montre le
chemin parcouru
cet article qui est très court dit ceci
le présent accord marque la volonté
affirmée des parties de préserver
l'intégrité du territoire
l'unité nationale la forme laïque et
républicaine de l'état et de maintenir
la paix et la sécurité sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
je pense que lorsque sont apposer la
signature à la fois du gouvernement
malien et des rebelles du nord cela
signifie qu un grand succès a été obtenu
et je vais à nouveau vous remercier
parce qu'il est due notamment à
l'unanimité de la représentation
nationale
merci la parole est un gérard césar pour
le groupe ump
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre guillaume garot chers collègues
alors que le salon mondial vinexpo se
tient à bordeaux cette semaine où nous
ait rencontré monsieur le ministre lundi
je suis élu de la gironde viticulteur et
président du groupe d'étude de la vigne
et du vin du sénat je suis inquiet je
dois dire très inquiet en effet la suite
à décision de la commission européenne
de lutter contre le dumping chinois sur
les exportations de panneaux solaires à
l'europe a les surtaxes à la chine
envisage des mesures de rétorsion sévère
sous les exportations européennes de vin
en particulier la phrase premier
fournisseur avec un million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et 140 millions de
litres vendus en 2012 pourrait subir de
plein fouet ce qui n'est pas encore une
guerre commerciale mais qui pourrait le
devenir
bordeaux est le principal veut importer
en chine avec 20% de sa production café
la commission européenne
les panneaux solaires chinois se voient
imposer des droits de douane hauteur de
11 80% depuis le 6 juin 2013
ils passeront en 47 % le 6 août prochain
si aucun accord n'est trouvé avec la
chine d'ici là le commissaire européen
espère bien avoir une soixantaine de
jours pour parvenir à une solution
négociée
je trouve que c'est bien l'eau quelles
sont les mesures envisagées par la chine
immédiatement elle annoncé l'ouverture
d'une procédure d' enquête antidumping
et antisubventions sur les vins importés
en provenance union européenne nous
avons d'un bordelais la preuve formelle
que certains importateurs chinois et je
voulais rappeler monsieur le ministre
lundi ont déjà pris des mesures
coercitives qui se concrétise par des
noms expédition de conteneurs de 20 en
chine
nous savons qu'il n'ya pas de dumping
sur les vins européens des subventions à
la production de vin en france comme en
europe oui la france l'union européenne
respecte les règles de l omc a revanche
les syriens les chiliens sont en train
d' abaisser leurs droits de douane pour
prendre les parts de marché en parallèle
le prenons très au sérieux ce qui n'est
peut-être qu'une stratégie face à une
europe qui n'avance pas sur des lieux
tout comme les allemands ne souhaitons
pas une gradation et différents
contentieux un projet de réunion des 27
membres de l'union européenne est
évoquée par le président de république
en vue de rapprocher les points de vue
de cette négociation avec la chine
qu en est-il monsieur le ministre
j'ajoute et j'en termine que le désarroi
actuel de la filière vitivinicole risque
d'être aggravé par la fiscalité
comportementale sur le vin qui serait
plus monétaire que pédagogique
le groupe vigne et vin du sénat s'est
opposé à l'unanimité à cette proposition
d'un enrichissement de la fiscalité sur
le vin qui dispute seulement qui
pourrait déstabiliser gravement la
filière merci des paroles est à présent
monsieur guillaume garot ministre charge
de l'agroalimentaire merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur vous
l'avez dit la chine a ouvert une
procédure anti dumping et anti
subvention auprès de l' omc
s'agissant des vins européens et nous
l'avons dit avec stéphane le foll
l'union européenne communiquera toutes
les informations nécessaires pour
répondre aux questions posées par la
chine comme le prévoit la procédure
mais je veux le dire à mon tour le
secteur ne reçoit pas d'aidé directe à
l'exportation
nos vins ne bénéficient pas de l'aide de
subventions deux mesures donc de dumping
les seuls les seuls soutiens qui sont
apportées portent sur l'amélioration du
vignoble et sur la promotion des
indications géographiques et donc ce
type de mesures n'est pas de nature à
distordre le commerce international
quoi qu'il en soit l'europe ne doit
jamais négliger sa force de marcher et
le poids qu'elle pèse lorsqu'elle parle
d'une voix unie d'une voix cohérente
c'est pourquoi et vous l'avez rappelé le
président de la république a appelé à
une convergence des positions entre les
27 états membres de l'union
alors monsieur le sénateur nous
comprenons bien évidemment les
inquiétudes de nos viticulteurs parce
que la chine est un pays où la présence
française est forte est importante mais
je veux le dire aussi
ici ni l'europe ni la france ni la chine
n'ont intérêt à une guerre commerciale
nos différents aujourd'hui ne porte que
sur 1%
je dis bien un pour cent de nos échanges
et donc nous devons plus que jamais
privilégier la voie du dialogue un
dialogue que nous voulons approfondie
régulier et qui doit se traduire par une
discussion en permanence ouvert c'est ce
que nous ferons demain dans le cadre de
la commission conjointe union européenne
chine sur le commerce et l'industrie et
vous le savez en tout cas je vous le dis
ce dossier sera abordé
retenez une chose nous ne sommes pas
dans une
ic de surenchère nous ne sommes pas dans
une logique d escalade mais bien dans
une logique de transparence et soyez
sûrs que le gouvernement reste bien
évidemment très mobilisés très attentif
très vigilant mais en même temps tout à
fait serein sur l'issue de cette
procédure
je vous remercie merci la parole à
monsieur philippe paul pour le groupe
ump
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse également à monsieur guillaume
garot est relative à la situation de
l'industrie agroalimentaire dans le
finistère
monsieur le ministre depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant l'industrie
agroalimentaire du finistère traverse
une crise brutale d'une ampleur sans
précédent en février dernier
l'abattoir gad à lampaul-guimiliau était
placée en redressement judiciaire
à ce jour aucun repreneur ne s'est
manifesté aucun faisant peser une menace
de fermeture du site en août prochain et
la disparition de près de 850 emplois
début juin la société marinard ouest
kristen spécialisée dans la
transformation de saumon annonçait la
fermeture l'an prochain de ses sites de
poullaouen dans le finistère et de
châteaugiron en ille-et-vilaine soit la
suppression de plus de 400 postes au
total en l'espace de quelques semaines
ce sont plus de 1000 emplois qui sont
remis en cause sur le finistère
plus de 1000 emplois c'est une véritable
tragédie pour les familles pour
l'activité des communes concernées et je
pourrais également évoqué le groupe doux
toujours en redressement judiciaire qui
depuis un an a perdu près de 1000
emplois lui aussi monsieur le ministre
vous connaissez bien l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire bretonne et
finistérienne vous connaissez leur poids
dans l'économie régionale
elles en sont les moteurs élus salariés
acteurs économiques locaux ont
clairement exprimé leur détermination et
leur volonté de se battre est de
rechercher des solutions pour sauver ces
différents outils de production et de
transformation pour ne reprendre que
l'exemple de l'abattoir gad n'est-il pas
incompréhensible et paradoxale
d'envisager la fermeture d'un outil
performant
implanté dans un des bassins de
production porcine les plus concentrées
et les plus dynamiques d'europe qui de
plus réuni tous les agréments
nécessaires à l'export
n'est-il pas incompréhensible et
paradoxale d'envisager la fermeture d'un
outil qui permet de produire et de
transforme été transformée par don au
plus près d'une zone de production et de
garantir ainsi une traçabilité parfaite
devons-nous nous résoudre à voir des
dizaines de milliers de porcs produits
en bretagne être abattue en allemagne
phénomène qui touche bien d'autres
régions françaises d'ailleurs monsieur
le ministre
quand on est vous faire pour éviter que
l'agroalimentaire bretonne et
finistérienne ne continue à sombrer
quelles initiatives fortes le
gouvernement entente il prendre pour
accompagner ces territoires
inquiet et à juste titre pour leur
avenir je vous remercie
merci monsieur guillaume garot ministre
chargé de la grande île en clair
monsieur le sénateur paul vous l'avez
vous l'avez rappelé certains pans de
l'industrie agréé agroalimentaire
traverse aujourd'hui une crise très
lourde et la bretagne en particulier
finistère n'est pas épargné vous avez
évoqué la situation de plusieurs sites
gad doux marine harvest et je vais vous
le dire pour chacun de ces sites nous
sommes au combat nous sommes au combat
pour trouver des solutions et pour
préserver un maximum d'emplois nous
avons rencontré les salariés de gamme
nous avons rencontré les salariés de
doux et nous rencontrerons dans les
prochains jours en lien avec stéphane le
foll et avec michel sapin
les salariés de marine harvest mais sans
attendre nous avons pris dès le mois
d'avril
je dis bien dès le mois d'avril avec
stéphane le foll des orientations fortes
à la fois pour répondre à l'urgence et
pour tracer de vraies perspectives
d'avenir et nous avons bâti en
particulier avec les professionnels un
plan pour relancer l'élevage pour
relancer la filière porcine et la
filière volaille en faisant de la
performance écologique un levier un vrai
levier de la performance économique
nous sommes engagés nous nous sommes
engagés
à assouplir les démarches
administratives pour les installations
classées en particulier hier
hier nous avons signé avec tous les
acteurs de la filière alimentaire un
contrat le contrat de la filière
alimentaire et ce contrat pourra devra
être mis en oeuvre très vite pour la
bretagne afin de stimuler l'emploi et de
moderniser l'ensemble de nos secteurs
enfin vous le savez nous avons travaillé
avec tous les élus avec tous les élus
bretons sur l'actualité et l'avenir de
notre filière agroalimentaire nous avons
organisé plusieurs temps de travail pour
mobiliser tous les acteurs concernés et
vous y avez d'ailleurs participé alors
monsieur le sénateur j'entends bien
aujourd'hui votre question nous sommes
pleinement conscients de la situation
tout à fait spécifique de la bretagne
sachez que nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied pour consolider et même
pour développer le potentiel agro
alimentaire de la bretagne parce que la
filière alimentaire doit rester une
force pour toute la région bretagne
merci la parole est à présent nos dames
françoise cartron pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans les tout
prochains jours la refondation de
l'école s'incarnera dans une loi
d'orientation et de programmation
ambitieuse issue d'un long travail de
concertation dont l'ampleur et la
qualité sont à saluer fruit d'un travail
parlementaire rigoureux et respecter ce
texte constituera sans contexte cette
feuille de route indispensable pour les
années à venir
cet après midi des centaines de milliers
de jeunes affrontent les épreuves du
baccalauréat
souhaitant leur pleine réussite mais
n'oublions pas qu'une partie de cette
génération a déjà quitté l'école sans
qualification et sans diplôme n'oublions
pas que les enfants des classes
populaires
sont les plus nombreux parmi les jeunes
en échec scolaire portes ouvertes hélas
vers l'exclusion sociale nous le savons
notre école ne parvient plus à corriger
ces déficiences
c'est pourquoi face à cette crise
éducative
malheureusement aggravée par les
politiques menées ces dernières années
des mesures d'urgence ont été prises dès
la rentrée 2012 mais aussi des réformes
de fond ont été engagés depuis un an
mesures difficiles parfois mais toujours
courageuse notamment autour de
l'aménagement des temps de l'enfant
c'est pourquoi la loi portant
refondations de l'école de la république
acte la programmation de 60000 postes
dans l'éducation nationale
un effort considérable en cette période
de grandes difficultés
mais au-delà de ce qui est inscrit dans
la loi
les parents d'élèves les enseignants les
jeunes ont besoin de comprendre les
critères d'affectation des moyens
déployés sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire
dès la prochaine rentrée scolaire quels
seront les traductions concrètes des
priorités du gouvernement
de plus afin de porter cette nouvelle
ambition pour l'école face à ses
nouvelles tâches à ces nouvelles
pratiques
les directeurs d'école appelle à être
soutenus et accompagnés
quelles réponses pour vous pouvons-nous
leur apporter enfin concernant le
principe d'une école inclusive
nous l'avons voulue dans la loi monsieur
le ministre
là encore quelles perspectives
concernant l'accompagnement éducatif
pour les enfants porteurs de handicap à
court et moyen terme
merci pour vous répondre monsieur
vincent peillon ministres éducation
nationale monsieur
résident mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
l'année dernière c'était la rentrée du
changement il faut que cette année ce
soit la première rentrée de la
refondation que veut dire la rentrée du
changement j'ai entendu certains
s'interrogeaient l'année dernière était
prévu 14 mille suppressions de postes et
il y en a eu 13 mille parce que nous
avons fait un plan d'urgence de 1000
postes et beaucoup d'entre vous sont
d'ailleurs venus me solliciter pour en
avoir dans leur région et ont été
heureux de constater qu'en particulier
des classes rurales 350 n'ont pas fermé
grâce à ce plan d'urgence
en 2005 la loi fillon a prévu une école
inclusive entre 2010 et 2012 le nombre
dette pour les enfants en situation de
handicap est tombé de 20 mille à cinq
mille le président de la république et
le premier ministre me permettent de
vous annoncer aujourd'hui qu après
l'annonce des 10000 postes pour aider
les directeurs d'école 8000 postes
seront consacrés à nouveau à la rentrée
pour accompagner les enfants en
situation de handicap
il y a les discours et il ya les actes
cette année sera l'année de la
''refondation'' parce que vingt mille
stagiaires
vingt mille élèves professeurs auront à
nouveau l'année de stage et pourront
bénéficier des écoles supérieures du
professorat et de l'éducation dont nous
avons parlé parce que à cette rentrée
6700 postes seront créés et ces postes
seront créés à parité exacte entre le
primaire et le secondaire ils seront
affectés pour une partie d'eux-mêmes je
prends le primaire à l'augmentation du
nombre d'élèves 35000 dans le primaire
sur les 3000 ce sera mille et tous les
autres postes seront affectés en
priorité dans les endroits où il ya le
plus de besoin car le mal le plus
terrific de notre école et que vous avez
évoqué c'est qu'elle accroît les
inégalités sociales
nous voulons non seulement la
massification mais nous voulons la
réussite de tous et c'est pourquoi 2000
postes iront spécifiquement vers les
zones urbaines sensibles et les zones
rurales en difficulté elles viseront des
pratiques pédagogiques dont nous savons
qu'elles doivent assurer demain l'art
lucide des élèves qui est notre unique
obsession l'accueil les moins de 3 ans
le plus de maîtres queux de classe
l'encadrement aussi des élèves pour
accompagner l'individualisation
c'est la mobilisation de toute la nation
dont nous avons besoin
je remercie une fois encore le sénat et
son texte a été adopté tel qu'il était
sorti de vos débats à l'assemblée
nationale
je remercie encore une fois le sénat de
nous avoir aidés dans cette entreprise
je le redis si l'école de la république
est capable de se ressaisir et la charte
de la laïcité sera aussi mise dans tous
les établissements à la rentrée de la
même façon que notre devise sera sur le
fronton comme le drapeau de la
république et le drapeau européen de
tous nos établissements
si nous sommes capables de refonder
l'école de la république nous serons
capables de redresser le pays merci mes
chers collègues nous avons fini avec des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance sera reprise
assez heureux qu elle a donc pour cette
séance des questions d'actualité cet
après midi au sénat on se retrouve tout
de suite avec nos invités pour refaire
cette séance a tout de suite
voilà après les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement cet après midi au sénat et
bien nous refaisons maintenant la séance
avec différents invités pour traiter
avec eux deux ces questions d'actualité
tout d'abord pierre laurent secrétaire
national du parti communiste français
sénateur de paris bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en face de vous gérard larcher
sénateur ump des yvelines
bonjour et merci à vous aussi d'être là
on va parler la conférence sociale
ouverte ce matin à paris par le
président la république gérard larcher
tout d'abord vous qui avez été muni du
travail sur la forme mais ce que vous
approuvez la méthode finalement jamais
les partenaires sociaux n'ont autant été
associés c'est pas tout à fait exact en
fait c'est l'application de la loi de
janvier 2007
un texte que je connais bien parce que
je l'avais défendu c'est ce texte qui
prévoit l'agenda social mais je crois
tout ce qui relève du dialogue social
est positif donc sur la méthode je ne
peux que partager car c'est vraiment la
démarche qui me semble j'allais dire la
bonne démarche mais après c'est le
contenu et le résultat alors on va
détailler mais c'est vrai qu'il ya quand
même des questions qui se posent de
pierre-laurent autour du tempo est ce
que cette méthode n'est pas un peu trop
longue il ya d'abord un rapport après il
ya la période de la concertation puis
finalement les décisions qui sont prises
par le gouvernement
est ce que finalement face à l'urgence
de la crise il ne faudrait pas aller un
peu plus vite
il faudrait aller plus vite sur un
certain nombre de questions mais en
l'occurrence c'est pas la méthode de la
conférence sociale enfin c'est pas le
fait qu'elle soit trop long qui soit en
cause au contraire on a été très vite
sur des réformes très importantes et
malheureusement de mon point de vue très
mauvaise comme l'accord national
interprofessionnel qui a été signé dans
la foulée de la précédente conférence
sociale et là on s'apprête à préparer
une réforme sur les retraites
on nous dit que la consultation va durer
uniquement cet été pour aller vers un
projet de loi en septembre
c'est évidemment pas une bonne période
pour mener une contre une
concertation sociale vraiment ouverte
donc on est plutôt dans un timing à
géométrie variable
on va lentement trop lentement sur des
sujets où il faudrait aller vite et on
va trop vite passé à quoi c'est un
exemple par exemple il faudrait sûre en
matière d'emploi prendre des mesures
importantes pour juguler les procédures
de licenciement les licenciements
boursiers alors qu'on l'ait facilite au
contraire notamment avec l'ani et au
contraire on va très vite vers des
mesures qui sont très inquiétants pour
le monde salarié donc on est dans les
deux cas à côté de ce qu'attend le monde
du travail gérard larcher